any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome everybody to this special
episode of the into the impossible
podcast
i'm your fearful host professor brian
keating
at university of california san diego's
arthur c clarke center
for human imagination and today we have
a very special guest
new york university professor charles
seif
joining us all the way from the east
coast somewhere although it's hard to
tell
out the window the the view isn't quite
as good as it is here in san diego but
charles how are you where are you
joining us from today
i'm great i'm in the suburbs of new york
right now uh
my house is under renovation so i'm in
i'm actually in my mother's house
well it's uh you know it's it's just a
return to normalcy
in these wonderful pandemic podcasting
times
uh i wanna i wanna thank you first of
all for coming on the show
and second of all for doing a service to
uh to physicists
in particular we're gonna go deep we're
gonna nerd out uh and that is to discuss
your wonderful new book
hawking hawking which comes in the heels
of very many scientific
journeys in uh so-called popular writing
uh this one is is from basic books a
fine imprint
and uh and i've devoured the book i have
it in
all well at least two different forms
but i have two copies of the hard copy
uh one copy of the kindle and soon to
get the audible
book as well it comes out next month in
june we'll probably time the podcast to
come out around that time
i've loved all your uh writings and and
so forth i followed you
let me ask you a question you're a
professor of journalism correct
how does a journalist know so much about
science that he or she can talk about
uh four-dimensional wic rotations and
talk about
uh penrose diagrams uh and the
difference between a panerai's diagram
for a black hole versus a penrose
diagram for a singularity
in the big how do you come to this level
of uh of
intellectual parapathetism
well i i had a strange path as a
journalist i actually
trained as a mathematician
when i was an undergraduate i i always
thought i was going to be a phd
mathematician i actually switched from
physics to mathematics
long story there um but uh so i thought
i was going to do
pure math and i was studying i went to
graduate school um i picked up an nsf
uh grant for super computer time and i
came up with a thesis that i could do
and i was realizing that you know with
with moore's law
um if i'd hold off for six years
it would just solve itself so i was kind
of depressed that
okay so my entire corpus of work was
just buying some time
and i happened at the time also to get a
uh i liked writing so i got a
internship at the economist to do
science journalism
and i went over there for a few months
and i said
forget this math thing i i found my
calling and so i
spent my life writing about math and
science
uh physics in particular was my my real
passion for uh because as a journalist
kind of
understanding i'm i i can't say i have a
total understanding since i'm not
embedded in the physics but
having that extra level of knowledge
really gave me a leg up and i i
it's an exciting time as you yourself
know how
how cool this stuff that we've learned
in the past 20 years
yeah it's really a golden age not only
for you know scientific journalism but
for science itself especially cosmology
and many of the topics and subjects you
talk about in this book
which has a wonderful name called
hawking hawking the selling
the selling of a scientific celebrity
published april 6
by basic books as i said and we have a
lot of friends and and contacts in
common and
and uh and i love the book and i said i
thank you because i had on uh character
who's in the book
uh leonard milad now uh on this podcast
about six months ago to discuss his book
on stephen hawking a memoir of
friendship
and uh yeah of course you know that's a
delightful book and and he's he's waxing
rhapsodically about his late uh great
colleague
and friend but during that conversation
i revealed to him that i had heard
stephen hawking speak
in 1995 at a royal academy meeting i
happened to be in london
and i said how often do i get a chance
to hear stephen hawking and so
i lie in these streets like a rock
concert that you describe in this book
whenever he would speak and this is kind
of at the height of his fame just a few
years after um the book that looms large
in your book hawking honking is a brief
history of time we're gonna spend a lot
of time talking about that
but i remember going there and listening
to the talk and that was back when he
could respond in
what i call you know quasi real time
where you could ask a question after a
lecture
and it didn't have to be submitted ahead
of time a young person asked him a
question professor hawking
i have a question why did you write a
brief history of time it's rumored that
no one who has bought it has actually
read it cover to cover
and that nobody understands it why did
you write this book and he said very and
i'll never forget he said
because my daughter needed to pay for
boarding school
and i laughed everybody laughed um but i
remember talking to
em a lot now and i said if i was writing
a book this is before i knew about your
book uh charles
i would be called hocking incorporated
but i actually prefer your title better
but i realize he's a business man as
jay-z would say he's not just a
businessman he's a business
man and and he had to have an industry
but i came away from that conversation a
little bit more sympathetic to stephen
because
i learned he had to be turned over in
the middle of the night
you know for basically most of his life
his tracheostomy would clog he would
choke to death almost every day or you
know the danger loom large
um so i want to ask you first um first
of all you write you
validated that story in the book so it's
not just my uh senior moments
uh you know that he did actually say
that explicitly on numerous
occasions as he would often do and
what's so i'm wonderful about your
scholarship and this book is
it's got 30 pages worth of footnotes
basically and references
uh it's a work of scholasticism that
actually is very good
charles for physics majors and i'm going
to give this to physics majors i've
actually given it to one of my uh
primary students
already because it's actually a great um
a book for treating
uh subjects in black hole physics and
gravitational physics and learning the
history as we often don't
i want to ask you though um it must have
taken a lot of courage
to pitch a critical biography of
basically a man who's been elevated to
the status of saint um
not so much within physics but within
the billions of people worldwide who
found him to be the most recognizable
scientist
how challenging was it for you to write
a criticism of a saint
uh anti-gay geography i guess you'd call
it and um
have you faced any blowback since that
time
yeah uh well i i think i went into this
a little naively uh
i mean i i i knew um
that hawking had this symbolism that was
great
i knew that um trying to talk about the
real person behind the symbolism was
was not going to be popular in some
circles but um
i had spoken over the years
to people within the cosmology community
within the
physics community who would talk frankly
about
hawking's place in their universe and
so i thought that it wouldn't be so hard
to write this up in such a way where
people were
people would frankly just talk about him
and celebrate him as a person
um and it turned out to be a lot harder
than that because
you're absolutely right that it it it is
like
uh going and kicking the shins of mother
teresa
in some ways uh even though i i mean i i
tried very hard
uh not to make it a hatchet job not to
kind of wallow in
this bad parts of his personality all of
us
have parts of their personality that if
you had a biographer go after you you'd
probably be embarrassed about i mean
that's
that's human nature um but
at first i actually had a bit of
difficulty selling it
um it took a while to kind of
fewer publishers were interested than i
expected um
and it's actually the first book that i
have done with
basic everything else i've done has been
with viking
um so there was that and then
people i've spoken to over the years and
have been very frank about kind of their
work and
hawking's work and all that would
just refuse to speak to me even once
i've had very good relationships with in
the past
and i think it's not just people who
were close friends with him and want to
preserve
that image but it's also his antagonists
who
really didn't want to look like they
were getting into the slugging match
especially after this this
symbol he died not so long ago it was it
was tragic and to speak
badly of the dead even though i wasn't
trying to elicit the dirt it was really
just
trying to get it who he was and who he
was is so much more interesting
than kind of a symbol as i hope we all
are i mean it's
we're we're all more than carick and of
course you know his
his uh character was intimately
connected to uh
to his disability to his als uh disease
and and in that sense it's not only
speaking about the dead it's it's you
know
you risk all sorts of uh of of pushback
and blowback perhaps because you're
criticizing someone
with profound disabilities who overcame
them despite this death sentence at an
early age
but what i um what i found so uh so
delightful about the book is that
you don't you don't treat them with pity
in fact i think you treat them with
respect
and to assess his legacy with respect is
i think one of the highest honors one
can afford
and i i just want to salute you for
doing that for having the courage to
write this book
and um you know and i'm sure there has
been because there is basically this
industry and now that he's gone
you know it's ramped up even more i mean
we did a special episode
of the into the impossible podcast which
i'll put a link i think it'll appear up
here
uh the link to it uh with my colleague
dr
doctor doctor he's a real doctor and
he's also a phd
eric virey who's the director of the
arthur c clark center for human
imagination
he and peter diamandis who was also a
guest on the
podcast and who appears in the book um
they were the flight surgeon so to speak
for his
stephen's zero gravity flight uh which
you recount in the book
and we did an episode right after he
passed away and i've done multiple
episodes including with his uh late
friend
he's not late thank god roger penrose
who's become a good friend of the show
and
we actually talked about whether or not
you know stephen would have garnered a
nobel prize
uh in recent uh in the recent nobel
prize that was offered this past
uh this past year and of course i've
spoken out against the nobel prize as
another form of hagiography
it does appear in your book many times
but but i want to first turn to stephen
as a as a physicist and then we can get
into
uh stephen as a as a writer because
actually
i'm a little bit more you know now
impressed by steven's books
first of all it came out when you and i
were in high school basically
and that book a brief history of time
really was an inspiration for many
physicists to go into physics and to
learn more about it
but i do feel like there has been a fast
one pulled over not only
most of the scientific community who you
know every 20 years you have to go back
and rewrite all of scientific history
right
um but but also on the public and that
is that
um the main goal that stephen had was
twofold in his life as i see it at least
with regard to theology
he wanted to invalidate or in you know
this inviscerate the need for a god
and he did so in two ways one was that
he claimed the two roles that god had
would be
to um in you know initiate the universe
and then instantiate physics so you can
think of you know creating this the sim
city
and then giving it rules and laws and
those are the two things in a brief
history of time he claims he utterly
devastates the need
for uh for god to initiate the universe
in a grand design he eviscerates the
need to
have a god to instantiate the laws of
physics
uh where was he wrong in the first in
the first instance of a brief history of
time
uh you know in invalidating the need for
god to create time
where is that argument off the rails
from a physics perspective
mathematicians perspective yeah um
well i again i'll i'll say that again
i'm a journalist and not a physicist
so uh to nobody's perfect charles
nobody's perfect
well one would say that being a
journalist is far more
imperfect than other people but um
so yeah it's i mean the the taking down
the no boundary
um hypothesis i i i
let's let's put it this way i mean i
when i was
reporting on cosmology daily um
i didn't really encounter very many
people who took it seriously
uh in the sense that the
i mean i never really got a sense of
whether it was because
the it required this whole different
mechanism
uh the mathematical formalism that
people weren't comfortable with which is
a lot of the excuse that i
got or whether they really just didn't
buy it as a whole
and i never really formed an
opinion external to that but i just got
the sense that it
was not mainstream
and i guess that feeling kind of
i i picked up that feeling in fact
actually in reporting this book i spoke
to
some people who are much more diehard
about it
um than most others and
i mean what they said to me is that i
mean and even they really didn't buy
the details because when you look at it
and neil turock told me
kind of the more you look at the fine
parts of what
the no boundary proposal was
there's less there there that the the it
it kind of dissipates into a mist as you
try to kind of
uh burrowed down into the details uh
but the people who admire it do say that
it was
really kind of a bold attempt to do
exactly as you're saying kind of
but in it in more mathematical terms is
to kind of
have to sidestep the whole question of
determining boundary conditions
um and the theological interpretation of
course got
uh hawking into trouble with uh
philosophers whom he
was battling with all his life um
i still am a of the mindset that i i
mean i i
it isn't mainstream i don't think it
really answers much and later in his
life
he kind of was using because some of the
most elegant elements
of the no boundary assumptions like all
these universes had to be compact
um blew up later on and so as and
so he was relying more and more upon
fixes
and clutches and anthropoism to fix it
all and
it just seemed less and less elegant to
me
so do i have the physics chopped to say
no this is garbage
i i would not claim that but it is less
and less appealing over time especially
as the kind of
initial simplicity um dies
to fix it to fix the problems that he
was finding
especially i mean not least of which the
initial version
kind of forced a big crunch that because
of the
bactification all the universes had to
be compact you had to have
a closure and uh turok showed that that
wasn't true but
uh that was a prediction
and it failed uh and so i mean
i i have a lot less confidence in things
yeah i mean the the most damning
condemnation
of the trick which my my
very astute audience will be familiar
with is a property
of uh analytic you know calculus and
analytic geometry called a wick rotation
uh and actually the most damning
condemnation of it is hawking's words
himself so i quote
in any from a brief history of time uh
in any case as far as everyday quantum
mechanics is concerned
we may regard our use of imaginary time
and euclidean space
time as merely a mathematical device or
trick
to calculate answers about real space
time and and you have such a delightful
uh approach to this
you you you constantly remind the the
reader that that he was calling this a
trick
and and then you you further reinforce
it by saying calling it imaginary
uh space and imaginary and imaginary
time rather than space time which is
what all physicists work in
so physicist aboard a trick as much as
uh nature aborts a vacuum about which
hawking also had much to say
i might dispute that actually and in
fact this this
this uh goes partially to why i went in
mathematics
rather than uh physics because i
i was in quantum mechanics and all these
uh functions they were uh again they
said well it's it's zero
because it's it's it's an odd function
but it goes to infinity and not to
infinity
and so it's really non-integral
my head was exploding over the tricks
that were used
obviously the mathematics held up if you
did it he was he was trying to save us
some steps but uh yeah i mean uh
tricks tricks are accepted when they
work
that's true yeah vineman who plays a
huge role in the book too
uh sort of a foil for gelman and a foil
for when hawking
interacted although hawking had great
respect for feynman uh i don't know if
the converse was necessarily exactly
true
um but uh but yes this this this no
this wick rotation this tricky wicket
sticky tricky wicket um i don't know how
to say it but but the point is you do
this wick rotation
and then you transform the time
dimension effectively into a space
dimension which allows you to overlay a
metric on it
and then you're able to do uh findman
path integration which only works
in euclidean signature metrics or
minkowski space if you like
and so you're absolutely right and so
none of my physicist colleagues
uh apply this i don't know a single
physicist who applies
you know wic rotations and and the
hawking hard on no boundary
um uh you know conjecture as anything
other than
you know a curiosity that led to the
fame of stephen hawking in some sense if
they know it at all and in fact i didn't
read
i didn't finish a brief history of ty
started when i was 18
and i didn't finish it until two years
ago um
because i felt like you know he was such
a towering figure and and i know um
one thing about the book i feel like
it's very well written i
feel like even though you make this
patch writing and and readers should
read what what that means and
and charles you're you're uh they're
really the best person in the world i
think who
can comprehend you know not at the full
level of a theoretical physicist
although that's not me either
i'm a simple experimentalist uh but uh
but at the level of
a journalist looking at like well is
this plagiarism can you
plagiarize yourself all these things i
found incredibly interesting um
but i leave that to the to the readers
to to enjoy on their own
uh but from a from a uh just from a late
audience
reading perspective now putting taking
off my professional physicist
at he is a delightful writer and it's
impossible not to
detach his mischievous mercurial nature
um but of course people didn't know the
real him and in fact i brought this
up uh with paul steinhardt who's another
character of figures heavily in this
book paul's a mentor and a friend of
mine
two-time guest on the into the
impossible podcast and i actually never
knew
about their uh their embattled feud and
actually this earlier this year paul and
i were talking
i'd given a talk at the simons
foundation and paul and i had been
talking
about well what is the state of of
affairs in
you know in kind of the multiverse uh
you know perspective which which which
uh paul is
vehemently against and uh and i said
well here's what hawking said in verse
edition three you know he talked about
the hawking heartless theorem he talked
about the no
boundary and that's more than ever
people are beguming to see that it's
you know it's to be taken seriously this
is in 2016 so after bicep two
uh the inflation you know claim was
retracted etc
um and he says and then in the grand
design which he references obliquely in
the second or third edition of brief
history of time that i read
uh he says that that's taken even more
seriously than ever now that's step
two in his evisceration of god let's
talk about that
the grand design what was the purpose
there it was to in my mind
invalidate the need for a god to
instantiate the laws of physics
um what is the perspective that you
bring or that you discovered in the
writing of this book how seriously is
that
approach taken the invocation of m
theory to accomplish these uh very very
lofty goals of
of instantiating the laws of physics
itself
yeah um hawking's own
interest in m theory was really not deep
that he
got into it late and was
more or less dragged kicking and
screaming into it because
of some results which were butting up
against what he was doing
um really that's when he truly engaged
with it
um he at the time he was writing brief
history of time and
we're talking mid-80s he was
an n equals eight super gravity person i
mean he was always gravitational
physicist
he was not um he had
picked up uh field theories and such i
mean
during his time with calt at caltech he
was
immersed in in that um
sort of area but he was still a
gravitational physicist at heart and i
think
uh until um
the the uh and the and
the whitton um uh
work he he got in he really got
interest in when when n equals 11 super
gravity really gave you
this insight into all of
string theory m theory um
so and then he basically tasked his
graduate students to learn it for him
and bring him up to speed um
he used it himself to kind of shore up
some of the problems which
the no boundary uh
theorem was was showing the the the um
the fact that he had to kind of bring in
the anthropic principle
and uh reject the
uh the idea of uh a compact
universe and the idea of multiverse
versus him really appealed to him
because he could really
i think he re-envisioned the
no boundary his gestalt in
in the language of m theory but i don't
i i never got the sense that it was
fundamental to his thinking about it and
honestly if you
look at the grand design it is not that
dissimilar from a
brief history of time just updated a
little bit with the vocabulary
changed to a more modern version at
least that's that's
my take on it um maybe maybe
maybe uh dr blonde would would argue
that there's
something more deep to it and i i
and and certainly he he um has the
perspective
of 20 years of fighting over this and
his his
attacks on philosophy which again got
him in deep trouble in the press
uh reflect that but
honestly i don't i don't think the
fundamental nature of his arguments were
changing
much um it just it just took on a
slightly different cast i look at him
you know the i don't know how familiar
you are with biblical hebrew
uh but the uh the word israel in hebrew
the word itself means one who
fights with god in other words you're
wrestling with god you're saturated with
it because jacob the legend goes you
know wrestled with an angel
and then his name was changed from
yaakov jacob to
israel israel and that means because he
fought and wrestled and prevailed with
god
meaning that one should struggle with
god it's almost a definition
so i made a joke to leonard milano who
is you know at least culturally
biologically jewish
if not a theist himself i made a joke
that you know i believe that that
stephen was was deeply jewish
uh because he struggled so much with god
and
it's really saturated and his writing uh
is is replete with god
and i wonder if you can give a
perspective on that although
at different times in in both your book
and and um
and leonard's most recent book there
really is a
an impression that i get that you know
he would pay lip service to god i mean
it was rumored that he said
uh you know the uh you know every every
equation in your book reduces the
readership by half every mention of god
doubles the number of
sales that you make and we all must
hustle our books and and it's still his
book brief history of time remains a
best
seller and and it's really unparalleled
in popularity
and yet the end of the book ends with
this invocation
of the deity and saying things if we
come up with the theory of everything
which
he ultimately did not do although he was
never close he was never even working in
that field
that would unify all these laws together
we'll get to that um but the end of the
book is if we can get to a theory of
everything then we will truly know the
mind of god
and actually that does double duty
because uh
just last week i interviewed michio kaku
and his book the god equation so
you know charles if if mentioning god
one you know once in your book doubles
the sales what about you know the title
of the book if it has god in it come on
that's good yeah there's a god particle
article
uh yeah so so if if you can as a
physicist link your idea to to a deity
uh i'm not sure whether zoroastro
would work but uh yeah i think it does
help and i i
one of the things i wanted to find out
is actually whether he himself
pins that last line and i was not able
to get
ah that was my question uh yes did he do
that or did his editor
so some people say in the youtube
comments below uh that you'll see on
previous comments and i'm sure on this
video as well my audience is the most
astute
in all the multiverse if i believed in
such things uh but
uh but yes they they say no he was
forced to buy his editor and bantam
you know kind of did and there were
various times that even leonard you know
makes the case that yeah he would change
things here and there um
but more than that i think testifying to
his ultimate
um you know kind of prominence is that
not only did he invoke the name of god
but other physicists would invoke the
name of hawking most recently a guest
on the show leonard suskind who not only
like leonard malott now these these uh
you know theoretical
you know particle physicists love to
cite stephen hawking in the title of
their books
so so leonard had of course written many
books leonard
uh milad now wrote several co-wrote some
of the books with
uh stephen hawking in his later years
some say he played a role in
in the brief history of time is there
any truth to that
i don't yeah i don't think so either but
but uh and then leonard suskin invokes
the name of hawking
now i want to turn to this um to this
statement that everything
it said about that we know about stephen
hawking
is wrong uh in his lifetime i'm reading
from uh
from the publicity for this book this
wonderful book hawking hawking available
now from basic books
talking to the author who i feel is a
kindred spirit and
i salute his courage hawking was widely
seen as a genius on par with newton
but in reality he was by no means the
greatest physicist of his day
his early work on black holes was
groundbreaking but charles seif
professor at miu
today's guest argues much of his later
work failed to measure up to its promise
and physicists like roger penrose
ultimately
deserve more credit than hawking walk us
through that
was he at any point in time was he
anywhere near the stature of an eye
of a newton and einstein whose birthday
he shares his death day with
and uh other characters in the history
of physics
yeah i mean saying you're no newton
is not really an insult to physicists
i mean there aren't very many people who
could stand up to newton
uh who created an entire field and a
mathematical framework to do it
and to a lesser extent although almost
equally significant einstein
uh who also was struggling with creating
a mathematical framework
uh underneath it all and also
fundamental
um contributions to both
relativity and quantum mechanics at the
same time and
really a liminal figure
so so saying that hawking is no newton
or einstein's
that is kind of like a well duh but
for the fact that his
fame to a large extent rested on that
comparison that he
uh while at the same time he would hold
it at arm's length and he was very
explicit i am no newton i'm no einstein
i'm not galileo at this he would always
bring up in a sideways way
these comparisons his biographies which
he approved
would compare him to einstein and newton
he held the lucasian chair
so he had the uh intellectual uh
kind of the imprimatur of the the same
people who gave it to
uh newton uh and his
i mean he always used to say his
birthday was on the same day as galileo
300 years
earlier and he doesn't believe in method
psychosis i mean
he doesn't but but that sort of stuff i
mean it goes back to uh
uh was it a pythagoras who claimed he
was uh
the the reincarnation of a trojan hero i
mean the idea of this
this kindred spirit goes back so so he
while pushing it away he was very clever
at claiming it and
his i mean his gravestone another
question which i was
trying to get uh did he
design his gravestone or not or did he
describe the motto because it it is
in english exactly the same
uh as what is on uh newton's grave just
a few yards
yeah uh here lies what was is mortal of
stephen
hawking or isaac newton and why
um so yeah so that's that's not much of
an insult
um one of the biggest
insults that i mean i think
probably one of the things that in
reading reviews of his
his books that probably hurt him the
most was a colleague of his
someone who is kind of an academic
sibling had the same
phd advisor uh john barrow
um basically savaged
him um after his uh hawking's big
discoveries of hawking radiation and all
that
and said that none of it would survive
that it was not going to be looked at
in uh future generations and
there's some truth to that partially i
mean he was living in a quasi-classical
a semi-classical realm which he knew at
the very beginning was
wrong on some fundamental level uh and i
i mean he knew that hawking radiation
was real in the same way i mean
but he knew that he was working
with a theory that was going to i mean
his his mathematical framework was not
complete in a way that would give him
lasting uh fame like like newton or
einstein there was not that
mathematical breakthrough and i also
would argue that
um a lot of the i mean hawking got a lot
of the glory but
uh the person who i mean
really started the chain reaction that
led to hawking radiation
uh ultimately goes back to penrose um
and you he had a mathematical insight
maybe this is the mathematician in me
but kind of understanding
the application of some novel mechanism
to get this great insight and penrose's
insight was the singularity
uh that a black hole collapsing must
have a singularity and he
did it using topological arguments that
hadn't been used before
and it opened up this whole field and
hawking
to his credit this was not trivial i
mean it was really
interesting to apply that
to the birth of the universe and
um for and he did it the way everyone
talks about is he he realized that
reversing
time was uh if you if you see a black
hole
collapse in reverse it's a big bang but
there's some mathematical issues that
need to be sorted out to make those
equivalent and penrose was saying his
real insight was not this time reversal
but
making that mathematical structure work
so that he could
show that it applied as well
and so i mean i think that was a real
insight and it was it was important
um but by its nature it was
overshadowed by the father of that
field so um one has to kind of look at
his achievements
it's not in a vacuum it's not like he's
this lone genius who
appears and voila there's this
novel uh idea out there which
i mean newton you have an argument that
there is some
einstein even less so i mean i i think
if einstein weren't
born uh i mean juan correa was
going around the edges would it have
appeared
ten years later probably yeah hilbert
albert
yeah uh similarly like like if you if
you took out hawking if hawking
disappeared
how would physics be different today and
that's a really good question i'm not
sure it would be that much different
because i mean you have um radiation um
davies and
unrwa were there like three or four
years later
and that's really equivalent uh in some
beckenstein as you point out was there
two years before him right or five years
before
many years before right yeah
the the fundamental idea was back
instincts but but to be fair beckenstein
couldn't
bring it to completion he just couldn't
finish that um
but yeah i guess the question is i mean
for somebody
like uh like a hawking how you know
i mean how how reasonable is this so one
one thing i have and maybe we'll switch
to this
although um yeah let's just go there now
and then i want to ask you
um if you uh put on your journalist hat
and you're in a press conference or
you're in a private interview
and steven has to answer any one
question i'm going to let you pose that
question in a minute but before we do
i want to just take a break remind
people you're talking or listening to a
conversation that i'm enjoying so much
with uh with with really a kindred
spirit professor charles seif of new
york university
he was a mathematician you know at at
the beginning of his career and now as a
journalist or
a journalism professor at uh one of the
best universities in the world and i
want to talk to him a little bit about
that if we'll have time
uh but but before we do that i want to
just uh ask you remind you if you're
enjoying this please do
give a thumbs up and subscribe if you
would it helps us all out and please
check out
charles's book i'm going to have a link
to purchase it and i get
one micro cent for every purchase if you
use this amazon link that i'm going to
provide
and that's hawking hawking by charles
seif charles written eight books
nine bucks zero uh you've written many
other books that i'll have links to as
well
but charles now looking at these uh you
know kind of
theories and when i when i uh look at
things like m theory and i look at
hawking's contribution
and we look at the question you know is
inevitable should he have won the nobel
prize if he was alive or when he was
alive
um hawking radiation his signature
contribution
uh is and at least in the cases where he
believed that was already maybe evident
in the production of gamma ray burst and
stuff which was later ruled out
at the center as responsible for the
neutrino deficit in the
solar neutrino problem which was later
disproven um so almost all of his
physical connections were disproven
hawking radiation
you know in in our universe on average
would take of order 100 billion years
perhaps to observe
and yet and yet he would routinely
lose bets uh to fellow physicists
including to
uh kip thorne and lenny suskin who is a
guest on the show whose book mentions
him directly
how my battle with stephen hawking made
the world safe for quantum mechanics
uh so he's in the title of the book not
only god has mentioned but but
stephen hawking um a very very serious
physicist
why did he concede these bets uh you
know none of the work done
has any validity or any provability in
fact
the disproof of the destruction of
entropy which i believe or information
which correct me if i'm wrong and that
was hawking's position
that the entropy or information could be
destroyed in a black
hole and uh pressgill and thorne and
others bet him that it couldn't be and
he lost that bet like he did every
single other bet
uh but um why did he concede the proof
came from
juan maldasena using you know
holographic principle
ads cft you know five-dimensional you
know cosmology which
also don't exist so or proof from string
theory from ed whitten which we have no
evidence for
why would you why would he concede was
it part of his publicity stunt
campaign uh
to put it bluntly i think he wanted to
piss on that tree
uh because everyone else had kind of
done so
he was in the minority uh i mean there
are general
relativists who still hold that position
uh but
it really does uh it was even at the
time a minority opinion
probably that that um information
was destroyed um and i think he
came to believe the weight of evidence
was against him and
that rather than kind of
looking like um hold it holding to the
end as the ship is sinking he wanted to
uh take a lead in
reclaiming his paradox even through his
concession which
um was baffling to a lot of people
because
i was actually at dublin when he made
the announcement
and people didn't
understand what he was doing not at
least it would reason but was there
weren't enough details to really figure
it out
again it used the euclidean
uh the wick rotated uh formalism which
most people didn't use weren't familiar
with
he didn't give up enough detail even if
he were familiar with that to
explain his reasoning precisely so it
was kind of a
thumbnail sketch and it really didn't
convince
anyone but himself it was kind of an
interesting anecdote
uh that i got from the graduate student
who was announcing for him that even the
graduate student didn't
uh uh proof at that point it was it
wasn't
uh convincing to him so
yeah it was i i think it that that
concession
in particular was really to
keep his position at the forefront
leadership yeah and and this paradox
which is
kind of central and it's kind of it's
gotten this renaissance recently which
is just brilliant
um but he he wants to still be there
and uh if it meant kind of reversing
himself
i mean i think i think he realized that
he had to do it and but if
if he was going to do it he wanted to do
it his way yeah and he
would you know he would say things of
course and do things as roger
penrose said in one of my interviews
with him uh that i'll link to somewhere
in the
notes or above uh you know he said no
matter it was great to bet stephen
hawking because no matter which side you
took you'd always win
in other words he he not only you know
made but that's you know almost as if to
lose them but he would switch sides
midstream
uh he would concede things and i
remember seeing the bet with with um
with kip thorne uh you know at caltech
when i was at caltech
in the in the west bridge building and
uh but you know
but i always felt about him you know he
was known for these very provocative
things about you know god not being
necessary
you know god being a delusion a fairy
tale to let people sleep at night and in
doing so
god had great value only in doing so uh
he also said this this is one of the
most quoted
of his quotes that at least in humanist
circles
he said the human race is just a
chemical scum
on a moderate size planet orbiting
around a very average star
in the outer suburbs of one among a
hundred billion galaxies
we are so insignificant that i can't
believe the whole universe exists for
our benefit
that would be like saying that you would
disappear if i closed my eyes
this is like you know very awe-inspiring
very hopeful uh
you know kind of fair from him i want to
ask you if you were uh
to to get to have an interview with him
it was a it was a
you know barbara walters you know style
now it's charles seif style
uh what would you ask him he has to
answer it truthfully what question
would the journalist in you ask him
oh if he has to answer truthfully it's
different than
what i would ask him i'll give you both
i'll give you both you can do both yeah
so yeah um so uh
in ordinary circumstances for for me i
think i would press him
on falsification
of his ideas and at what point
would he have to abandon the no boundary
proposal
and um given how it's kind of
moved in different directions and some
of his kind of
subsidiary particle physics predictions
like the
non-observability of the higgs boson
fell apart
okay at what point do you realize that
you're barking up the wrong tree and
have to
make a major revision of your thought
so that that's that's kind of what i
would i would do
if i didn't have the golden glass uh
let's see if if he had if he were bound
to answer truthfully
i think
i would ask him
what the degree to which
um he really he regrets his
uh fame and what it's done what what
does he regret
about coming to fang because i i'm
really
interested in the interface at that
moment when he
rose to fame and at the same time he he
became estranged from
he uh he divorced his wife
uh kind of became estranged and then
wound up divorcing his wife and in fact
his children as well in the
years afterwards and it was only there
was a
at least a decade more than a decade
where he had
strange relations uh with with uh at
least one of his children
and i want to know more about that
turmoil
uh and to what extent he thinks
he's responsible and could have done
differently and to what extent
it was kind of just the circumstances
because because
there's certain elements of his
personality which kind of led to
tragedy and certain elements which are
just simply tragic um i i'm very
interested in the balance
yeah i mean that's certainly true i had
neil degrasse tyson
on a couple weeks ago and you know he
was i was asking about the impact
it's basically saying you know you're
the most famous living scientist you
know at least by you know twitter
accounting if not by h index
and you know and he said yeah what's
that
how's his kardashian index you know that
it's higher than his uh
than his urdosh number uh but the uh
the the claim that he made was that yeah
he can't even during covet
he can't even take the subway in your
fair city of new york
uh with uh with a mask on uh because
he's so famous people recognize him and
god forbid he decides to speak you know
his voice is so iconic and
and i really i asked him you know would
you trade at all uh as the story
in 1984 and sorry an animal farm by
george orwell
the pig says uh to the donkey benjamin
you've got this long lovely tail
and benjamin the donkey says yeah the
god gave me
uh this long tail to swat away the flies
but i'd rather not have the flies and
not need the tail
and i asked him how do you resonate with
that and he basically said yeah i just
want to go down to you know take a boat
to
to the bahamas and uh and just write
books all day long
and uh you know a little tear came down
my my chin but
you know i'm not gonna weep too much
maybe your next book will be a takedown
of neil degrasse tyson that
that would be an interesting book i
wonder if that could get uh published
but no no neil's a good friend of the
show and and uh and
we had a great conversation i'll put a
link to the talk with him up here
uh also i asked the same of michio kaku
and this turns us to our next
uh discussion topic which is about this
is just about
fame and so most physicists that are
good um
you know they kind of uh they earn in
private and then you know to some extent
they they spend in public you know if
they give a lecture
you know day to day like like roger
penrose he will
do a lot of work over decades uh and
then he will
uh and then he'll you know give some
lectures and he'll try to you know maybe
convince people of this conformal cyclic
cosmology which most cosmologists don't
take very seriously
um but in the meantime he's done
tremendous contributions to everything
from you know crystal structure
tiling map pure math black holes
singularities
cosmology uh it's just that his you know
current model is not so
steven seems almost the opposite or
maybe you know delayed
uh in that he you know he had this one
spectacular contribution
and then uh but basically all of his
earning you know was in was in uh
all of his spending and earning was in
public uh in other words he he didn't
really there were
if you look at his h index it's it's
very low you know he has a couple papers
that are signed thousands and thousands
of times
but his books are read millions of times
and i wonder you know what do you make
of this that there are people like
um like uh hawking like
uh you know brian green nowadays uh
crosstown rival at nyu
uh from nyu at columbia um and and other
lisa randall
et cetera uh machi okaku hopefully
someday brian keating no
but but the point being you know what do
you make of this you know scientific
scientist celebrity i mean no the even
hawking
didn't really fully compare relative to
his time no pun intended
as einstein did you know when day
einstein died time magazine printed a
special cover and it said
a picture of the planet with a sign
pointing einstein lived here
but you know einstein you know also did
a lot of great work turned 40
you know ish and and stopped really
contributing but but um
the fact that that hawking's singular
contribution
cannot be falsified or verified in our
time
unlike penrose perhaps um you know what
do you make of this that these phys
physicists come uh come you know rack
contours and
and and popularizers uh is that is that
a sign of decline you know in their
physical physics prowess or
is that something that's healthy for for
society if not for their own personal
h indices as we say yeah
good question um well first i don't want
to
understate hawking's contribution i mean
he was definitely a physicist of the
first rank
so i i don't want to kind of make it
look like he's going to
uh he he's a pretender in that sense
uh however i mean you're absolutely
right that there is kind of a
disproportionate
uh uh fame
that accrued because of the
popularization
um you know i i i'm all in favor of
scientists
going popular i think i think our
society needs more of that and
not just kind of the the science of the
first rank like i mean
uh george gamow and generations previous
i mean lots of people grew up with with
his books um uh just again a brilliant
physicist
and had he become a superstar i think
our society would have been the better
for it so i don't i mean i think
hawking's voice was was a good voice to
have i think
part of the reason it seems like it
fits so poorly in some ways is because
there's so
few others out there who
you would think given equivalent um
achievements would at least be a little
bit more prominent they may not be as
prominent as that but people kind of
bubbling around
really kind of the famous scientists of
our day it's it's
to the public it's it is i mean neil
degrasse tyson bill nye who's
uh really an engineer and uh
hasn't hasn't done uh his career isn't
doing science um and
uh i mean uh brian greene has some as
well but
i mean i i'm not sure that brian green
gets recognized on the street in the way
that neil degrasse tyson does
and certainly but not the way hawking
does right so um
i i think hawking's fame looks bizarre
just because there aren't
i mean that that's it's so rare
and he was so far above everyone else
i mean he needed it too i mean it's i
mean
he because of his disease had these huge
expenses
and his fame and his royalties
allowed him to live outside of a
communal setting i mean it's it's a
testament to his first wife it's a
testament to
his friends who got charities
uh holding it together for him and then
his his royalties kept him
functioning and uh contributing not just
to
physics i mean i mean even even after he
himself was not doing
um uh physics on his own real
great physics he was a phd advisor who
was
uh getting some of the best students out
there many of whom found him
inspirational
um so he he was
important to society i just again i just
i just wish it would
work so anomalous
that there are there are people who
should have
equal fame and are equally articulate
and have great
contributions and can write and uh can
lecture
and uh they don't get the same uh
element but
life isn't fair as hawking is the first
uh
so i want to close just by talking first
about the halo effect
in that just like einstein you know he
was really held in high regard in
regimes far outside of his discipline
of expertise you know in the same way
that einstein was asked to be
the second prime minister of israel you
know this is a man who
uh aboard nationalism so you know uh
so but because he was so bright and the
two men share another fatal flaw at
least in my opinion
uh in their characters which is that
they were kind of uh
terrible fathers in many cases i mean
einstein basically abandoned one of his
kids who
uh to a uh what they called a sanatorium
a mental institution what we might call
um you know today uh and uh and of
course hawking had this relationship
even with his kids and his wife his
first wife jane
uh that uh was really you know almost
like completely
dis disinterested and and and dis
disconnected
you talk about their first trip as young
you know post docs maybe to cornell and
and he's just like listening to wagner
and you know blasting the volume and the
kid is
you know almost dying you know joao is
choking to death at another point and
and she has to take care of him instead
of instead of uh her child her
two-year-old or one-year-old whatever
robert was at the time
um so you know both these men have these
huge flaws i wonder
you know is it true that just raw
intellectual horsepower
supersedes the aspects of one's
character i remember thinking
you know i've said this before you know
because i am a practicing jew if not
like a complete
theistic adherent i still practice my
you know i remember thinking you know
and saying at different interviews i've
given
you know that i don't believe that the
torah the old testament the bible
whatever
is a science book any more than i
believe a brief history of time is a
manual of wisdom and ethics and how to
raise my kids
so why why do we care so much about you
know the life advice or the ethical
teachings
of people that had really tortured you
know at best
you know relate personal relationships
yeah hawking hawking's background i mean
his relationship with his family was
complicated because of a situation i
mean it's it's
he was unable to rough and tumble with
his kids and be
a father in the same way that other
fathers could be
just because i mean it's not
a total explanation but does his
situation does limit him and
when he was interviewed a number of
years later someone asked
what he regretted about his disease it
was
that i wasn't there more for my children
so i don't think
that it is a total disinterest as much
as kind of the reality is getting in the
way
um but yeah i mean i i i think
that uh i mean he he he doesn't
if his intellect were all that he were
i don't think this public would have
been very interested
honestly um i think that there was more
to him and
even even disease aside i mean he was
witty he was and as you mentioned i mean
it shows in his way of of
talking to others his way of writing um
the self-deprecating humor
this stoicism the um i mean he's he
he's quite a character he's um
he can leave people laughing his
lectures were
would have people rolling um and i i
asked a number of them because because
so much of
time of humor is timing and he can't
learn things how does he how is he so
funny and they couldn't explain it but
it was just
his his personality worked and it it it
was
it was something warm about him too
um so i i i think he succeeded in a way
that say an edward teller
or a johnny von neumann would never kind
of become
um i think just out of their pure
intellect
uh but yeah no he is not someone to look
to
for moral advice is it is that again
which of us are there aren't very many
of us i i'd listen
to much less myself uh is it true that
you know his second
wife elaine uh she was a nurse right uh
one of his carers as he would call them
uh and then her husband was really the
the driving force be
behind steven's you know uh second voice
synthesizer is that
is that true yeah he engineered it so it
would fit on his wheelchair
uh that it was engineered by someone in
the states and
uh david mason and mason's husband
uh engineered and and um he wound up
servicing it long after his wife uh
left yeah i found that so bizarre uh you
know basically he
enabled the technology that steven
seduced his wife away from
and i so i he he just wouldn't talk i i
actually went to cambridge uh
and knocked down his door hoping that he
would answer and he
he actually did and he gave me this
look when i told him i was talking that
he just
the the kind of the sorrow and uh i i
i just can't talk about it i'm sorry and
that was
it well uh charles we've come to the end
of our conversation
i've really thoroughly enjoyed it now i
have to go and teach
i want to give you just a chance to say
a little bit about uh your teaching and
your role at nyu it's a
one of the world's foremost uh
institutions um how
how um what is your area of specialty
and and then
what could students expect if they are
lucky enough to get accepted and
matriculate
there in that fine university
yeah so nyu has a really nice journalism
department which is both undergraduate
and graduate
with the graduate side we have a science
uh
health and environmental reporting
program we call sherp and i'm attached
to that
and i teach science journalists how to
do investigative reporting
and so kind of getting your green eye
shade on and
getting into books and having a very
skeptical
sometimes view of science um
uh as opposed to the g whiz science
which we all
enjoy writing about but there's more to
journalism than that
and undergraduates i teach uh writing
generally i
i one of my favorite courses right now
is i teach programming for journalists
uh using python and we i teach them how
to do
web scraping and hooking up to apis and
doing data analysis uh which is
uh a lot of fun and by the end of the
semester they're actually
so journalists can learn to code wow i
thought we weren't allowed to say that
yeah absolutely it
what we're not allowed to say is that it
can help you supplement your income
uh just the last question just because
you brought it up you know science and
and
science journalism um i am vehemently
opposed to press conferences
uh in science as a modality of
disseminating information that makes it
into like a sporting event or a prize
match
um literally sometimes you know gunning
to to uh
you know be first in line to to win one
of these uh nobel prize medallions
uh which i happen to have from my nine
guests that have left
different things in my couch over there
uh but uh but what's your opinion about
press conferences are they
net good i mean first of all they're
relatively modern
phenomenon is that not right
relatively um that
there is kind of this engineering of the
science press because
the journals have these press releases
and for big things they have press
conferences and
the press conference after peer review
has
gone back decades press conference
before
peer review is a much more recent
the um a cold fusion fiasco was one
where
it really kind of the
ponzi fleischman held a press conference
so they could
uh gazumph uh jones
uh who is sniffing at the the same uh
direction yeah
so that sort of thing is is pretty
recent and i i think
that sort of stuff is it it is
problematic to say the least and i i i
put the kind of the engineering
generally uh as problematic because what
it's
doing is it's presenting a pre-packaged
narrative
rather than and and journalists
like all creatures that kind of do the
path of least
least resistance least action uh and
will
take that narrative instead of teasing
it apart
and as you know i mean the bicep tooth
thing is a great example of that
there was a kind of an embargoed press
package
that turned out to be giving a very
misleading impression of what was there
and
had people been going outside of the
narrative it's more likely that they
would have picked up some
uh signals that go against uh that now
that's right
yeah yeah uh i'm all for transparency
uh but you know my my goal is and if i
could ask you to do one thing
with your colleagues in science
journalism is really
convey to the scientific teams that
whatever dollars they
they reserve for publicity that they
have some fraction
to hedge against the possibility of
retraction
because as you know in the front page of
your hometown newspaper the new york
times would splash these results
and then maybe on page b17 of the
saturday edition which
i believe is the least read of all the
weekly edition uh
you know uh editions of an of any given
newspaper
then on b17 on saturday you'll see oh
bicep team or whoever retracts
you know claim that was above the fold
literally uh you know just
you know six months ago and so the
public has led i still get from
scientists
oh wow you were involved with bicep you
know that's so amazing you detected
inflation
and uh and so i think that you know
every every dollar needs to have at
least you know 10 cents 25 cents
in reserve um you know to guard against
the possibility that
you know if if 99 of three sigma results
are wrong you know i mean how much more
so of you know two sigma
and so forth so anyway that's my hobby
horse i i don't know if you agree if you
want to say respond to that uh kind of
provocative
oh yeah i definitely do and part of the
problem is that what journalism
often does and what makes people
interested in a story
is that it goes against what you expect
and what is normal and
so big results are automatically
abnormal
and of course in science things that are
abnormal are more likely to be wrong
which sets up science journalism for
failure before we even start
so there's a structural problem
completely amazing uh charles seif
professor nyu journalism
author of hockinghawking selling of a
scientific celebrity
zero the biography of a dangerous idea
alpha and omega the search for the
beginning and end of the universe
decoding the universe science of
explains of information
sun in a bottle proofiness uh i believe
maybe you're working on a book as we're
talking maybe your hand was hidden at a
show your hands
make sure that you're actually not
typing another book what's next nothing
nothing at the point
what's next for you i don't know
um right now it's uh this book was
fairly exhausting it was done during
covid and
uh doing that while my kids have
tremendous needs was very difficult so i
think i think this summer is going to be
kid time at the very least before i
well your kids and your students are
very lucky charles i mean that
sincerely i feel again this connection
um
you're a wonderful writer uh i envy your
students to be able to learn
from you uh especially python that would
be really fun
uh i've always i've always struggled
with python myself i'm more of an idl
fortran guy
myself but but anyway uh charles you're
you're really a shining light and no pun
intended in this field of science
journalism
you're also you bring a really uh a
special perspective that is unique
i want to thank you for this book
hawking hocking and i want to invite you
back whatever you do next
uh i'm i'm down for and hopefully we'll
meet in person someday when i'm back in
my former hometown as well
we'd love to see you